Okay, so June the 6th, 1924, "Louisa must cover the ways of all creatures and
enclose all that the divine will contains in her to be the starting point of the
fiat philanthropist's tour." In other words, Louise has to do everything that the
Lord is asking us in the divine will to do. It all has to be covered by her since
she's the first. Justice Blessed Mother had to do that in redemption as well. So
she said, "I was in the midst of my usual hard pains of his privation. I feel I'm
under the lash of justice that punishes me with such great rigor, with not even a
shadow of pity. Oh, punishing justice of God, how terrible you are. But you are
even more terrible when you hide from the one who loves you. Your arrows would be
sweeter to me if while you punished me, even tearing me to pieces my Jesus were
with me. Oh, how I cry over my lot." She has completely forgotten the lesson we've
just been reading about. That's the way it is with us, isn't it? Especially in
the spiritual life. We have a very short memory in the spiritual life. If everything
is going fine, we think we've always sailed along like this. And if we're
going through a hard time, you think you've never been out of the dark night,
absolutely ever, you know? And Louise is very good at that. Even more, I would want
heaven and earth everyone to cry with me over the lot of this poor exiled one who
not only lives far away from her fatherland, but is also left by her Jesus, who was
her only comfort and support in her long exile. So I've written James 511
beside that. James 511. Now, while my poor heart was swimming in the bitterness of
its pain, my adorable Jesus made himself seen in my interior, which of course is
Luke 1721, Kingdom of God is within you. He was holding as though many reigns in
his hands, and each reign was linked to a human heart. Now, the image that I see
as being described here is Jesus riding a chariot. Think of it, the chariots they
used in the ancient world, and he's holding many reigns in his hands. Now, the
person who's holding the reigns is the one who is in charge of what's going on
in the chariot. Each reign was linked to a human heart, so there were as many
reigns in his hands for his many existing creatures. And then he said to me, "My
daughter, the way is long, even more, each life of the creature is a distinct way.
Notice each person's life is unique. You may have many things in common with
other people, but there are certain things about you that have not turned up
before and won't turn up again, and you won't give the same responses as other
people. There is a particular part of the jigsaw that can only be filled in by, I
think, a very important thing to say. If you look at a picture like the one we
have on the wall there, a tiny little stroke of the pen can make an
indelible mark that completes that picture. Like if you take the little mark
that shows you the creases on the tablecloth, it seems very little, but it's
actually very important bit to show you the reality of the meal that Jesus and
the apostles were at. Okay? And it can be a very small thing, so I may be a very
small part of this huge painting that the Lord is actually making, but still
it's essential. And painters will tell you that that even tiny strokes make a
huge difference. So each one has a distinct way. I love that. I keep
emphasizing for people the uniqueness of their way, their call. Therefore, it
is necessary to walk much and to walk many ways, because Louisa was asked to
cover the ways of everyone who would walk in the divine will, therefore she
covered your way and mine. You will be the one who will cover all these ways
because since I must enclose my will in you, you must enclose all that it
contains, and it befits you within my will to cover all ways together and of
every person. Therefore, in my will, you have to do, and you have to suffer much.
Well, she would say definitely. On hearing this, oppressed and tired as I was, I said,
"My Jesus, this is too much. Who could do them? I'm already tired enough, and
besides, you leave me alone, and without you, I could do nothing." John 15 5, John
15 5, "If I had you always with me, then I could do them, but at last you leave
me alone, and I can do nothing." We've all proven that one, haven't we? And Jesus
added, "Yet I am in your heart guiding everything, one Corinthians 3 16." And you
can also put two Corinthians 6 16. Two Corinthians 6 16. "I'm in your heart, and
I'm guiding everything. And all these ways were covered by me. I enclosed
everything, and I let not even one heartbeat or pain of one creature escape
me. And you must know that having to enclose my will in you as the center of
life, it's necessary that my supreme volition find in you all the ways and
all that your Jesus did, because they are inseparable from it. It's enough not to
accept one thing, which, sorry, it's enough not to accept one thing alone, which it
contains, to prevent it from forming its center, from having its full dominion, and
from having its starting point in you, so as to make itself known and dominate
others. It would have it from itself, but not from you. See, then, how necessary it
is that you embrace everyone and cover the ways of all, taking upon yourself the
hardships, the pains, and the acts of all. I find it very difficult to take on
board in the real sense. I understand what's being said that Louisa took on my
acts and my struggles. I find that difficult. And this, if you want the
majesty of my will to descend into you, to follow its course within you. On hearing
this Louisa was surprised, and she said, "My love, what are you saying? You know
how poor I am, and in what state I find myself, and besides, how can I enclose the
whole of your will? At the most with your grace, I can do your will, and I can live
in it, but to enclose it is impossible. I am too little, and I cannot contain an
unending will." And Jesus said, "My daughter, it shows that you don't want to
understand. The one who wants to enclose this will in you must give you the
grace and the capacity in order to contain it." Now, there's a very important
statement. When the Lord asks you to do something, if he asks it, he gives you the
ability to do it. And what you've got to do is keep your eyes on him and not on
anybody else, and therefore you'll be able to do it. Not because you can do it,
it's because he's doing it in you. Realize that he would give you the grace
and the capacity in order to contain it. In other words, he gives us everything we
need. "Did I perhaps not enclose my whole being in the womb of my celestial
mother? Is it perhaps that I enclosed myself in part, leaving part of myself in
heaven?" No. And by enclosing myself in her womb, was she not the first one who
took part in all the acts of her Creator in all the pains identifying herself with
me so as to omit nothing of what I did. Was she not the starting point from which
I came out to give myself to other creatures? If I did this with my inseparable
mother in order to descend to man and to fulfill my redemption, can I not do it
with another creature, giving her the grace and the capacity to enclose my will?
Making her take part in all the acts it contains so as to form its life and to
come out as though from a second mother, now you know from Volume 2 he was asking
Louisa to be a second mother to him. To come into the midst of creatures to make
myself known and fulfill the fiat balances to on earth as in heaven. Do you
not want then to be the starting point of my will but oh how much it cost my
Queen Mother to be the starting point of my appearance on the earth? So will the
starting point of my will cost you that it may make its appearance in the midst
of creatures. One who must give everything must enclose everything. One cannot give
what one possesses, that's obvious. Therefore my daughter do not take lightly
what regards my will and what is befitting for you to do so that it may
form its life in you. It is the thing that interests me the most and you must be
attentive in order to follow my teachings. Now you're going to hear that in more
than one time as we go on because Jesus says that the way God works is that when
he wanted to do the work of redemption he chose our blessed mother to be the
person to start the whole thing off. Her fiat was absolutely essential that she
would have to enter fully into redemption so she was redeemed fully from the
moment of conception, okay. She was given the capacity and it was possible
therefore for the Son of God to become incarnate in her womb. She had to
participate in absolutely everything that he did and you know from Louisa that
even when they were separated when he was doing his ministry at times they
were separated they were fused so there was no separation. She knew
exactly what was going on and he knew exactly what was going on and so she
was completely fused with him in his dying and rising and absolutely everything
as well and he's telling Louisa that he needs her to do that on the divine
will level so that he can open the gate of the divine will to the rest of the
human race and he says I can't quote the volume in which he says it but he says
if one person does it completely I don't mind if the others do it partially
other people will will come and they will participate at the level that they
want but one person must have completed it totally so in the case of the divine
will that was Louisa so I think we leave it there and we'll go on to the next
volume the next time